ja willkommen zur heutigen Vorlesung wir
haben jetzt einen neuen Begriff
kennengelernt und zwar den Begriff der
Zurechenbarkeit und den habe ich jetzt
auch schon unser begriffsnetz eingefügt
und Sie können mal überlegen wo der
hingehört kann man natürlich wie mit
allen Begriffen schön drüber diskutieren
ich habe ihn jetzt mal
über
moralische Motivation getan auch wenn
man das natürlich noch genauer begründen
muss also ich zeig das mal kurz
ich habe ihn jetzt mal hierhin getan
aber man kann darüber natürlich
diskutieren wie auch
kollektiv für Personen
moralisch zurechenbar sein können oder
überhaupt zurechenbar sein können in der
Regel geht es aber um das Individuum was
zu euch ist zurechenbar sind der Regel
Handlungen
und hier steckt natürlich dann auch der
ganze begriffskomplex Wille und von uns
das steckte alles natürlich noch das mit
zusammen das hängt damit zusammen mit
diesem Begriff der Zurechenbarkeit das
ist ein ganz wichtiger Begriff und
natürlich hängt der Begriff der
Zurechenbarkeit auch mit dem Guten und
dem Bösen zusammen hat oder natürlich
der guten bösen Handlung und die
zugerechnet wird und darüber wird noch
heute diskutieren wir Wert aber erst
noch ein Rückblick machen nämlich auf
das Problem des Bösen und ich habe ihn
jetzt noch ein weiteres Zitat gebracht
was in meinen Augen sehr gut die
Problematik des Bösen darstellt diese
Zitat haben sie schon gestern
kennengelernt also das Böse das wieder
steht oder das entzieht sich
einer endgültigen Erklärung einem
endgültigen Verständnis ich glaube es
nicht aber viele Glaubens und die
argumentieren dann wie ein nicht
geringer Prozentsatz von ihm
hört die Irrationalität des Bösen oder
gegen die These dass das Böse irgendwie
vernünftig ist oder mit unserer Vernunft
was zu tun hat und in dieser in diesem
Sinne habe ich auch Zitat von Herrn
Schmidt biggemann angeführte es noch ein
bisschen
ja extremer ist es hat keine Logik eine
systematische Theorie des Bösen ist
nicht denkbar
starke these ich finde bevor man so eine
These äußert muss natürlich alles
unternommen haben
um vielleicht nicht doch eine Theorie
des Bösen zu entwickeln also nicht zu
schnell aufgeben dann haben wir noch ein
Zitat den kennen Sie vielleicht den
rüdiger Safranski wer kennt den von
ihnen rüdiger Safranski wer hat schon
mal was gelesen von ihm hat über das
Böse was geschrieben aus diesem Buch ist
die Zitat er hat eine ganz ganz
lesenswerte schillerbiografie
geschrieben eine sehr lesenswerte Goethe
Biografie natürlich hat er auch über
heiliger was geschrieben über ETA
Hoffmann über Nitsche ein ganz bekannter
Biograph falls sie mal freie Zeit haben
jetzt natürlich nicht weil jetzt müssen
Sie natürlich auf die Klausur
hervorbereiten aber danach wenn mal
wieder ein bisschen Zeit ist besorgen
sich doch das Hörbuch und hören das mal
unterwegs total entspannen total anregen
und der sagt jetzt das Böse gehört nicht
zu den Themen den man mit einer These
oder einer Problemlösung beikommen
könnte das Böse ist kein Begriff sondern
ein Name für das bedrohliche das dem
freien Bewusstsein begegnen und von ihm
getan werden kann
bin jetzt der rüdiger Safranski Recht
hätte mit seiner Aussage dass das Böse
kein Begriff sei dann dürfte ich es
eigentlich gar nicht in dieser Vorlesung
behandeln weil diese Vorlesung heißt
Grundbegriffe der praktischen
Philosophie also dann würde ich jetzt
praktischen Fehler begehen würde ich
jetzt eher so ein Zauberwort verwenden
also sofort ne was verschiedene
Assoziationen in ihnen erweckt ganz
verschiedene
Teufel und
blue crime und sowas ja und dann würde
ich mit ihnen eigentlich letztendlich
ja ein bisschen Begriffs asset Wort
Assoziation machen Fantasie Assoziation
betreiben und ich glaube es aber nicht
ich möchte hier Herr franzki entschieden
widersprechen das Böse ist in meinen
Augen und es werden heute auch noch mal
versuchen jetzt ansehen einer der
Grundbegriffe der praktischen
Philosophie natürlich auch und vor allem
der Moralphilosophie habe ich klar wir
müssen sehr ernst nehmen weil es ihm
eine extrem Dimension die letzte
Konsequenz von bestimmten Tendenzen in
uns darstellt die jeder von uns hat die
vielleicht nicht jeden Tag zum Glück so
deutlich zur
Erscheinung treten durch Morde Totschlag
und so weiter es gibt ja ein ganzes
Arsenal an bösen Phänomenen darüber
wollen wir heute auch noch ein bisschen
diskutieren oder reflektieren
assoziieren was alles in ihren Augen
böse ist ja nicht dass man hier einfach
mal so drüber reden wir wollen mal
konkret konkret sein ich glaube aber
dass das Böse Wurzeln hat also Anfänge
hat die alltäglich sind die kaum
auffällig sind die aber dann in ihrer
Radikalisierung am Ende zu verführen
können was man dann böse Handlung nennt
oder vielleicht sogar das Böse da bin
ich immer ein bisschen vorsichtig aber
das Böse zu reden ich mache oben rechts
sein in Youtube ein Link rein sondern
Diskussionsrunde im Schweizer Fernsehen
in der Gegend die Sternstunden der Nacht
da ging es um die Frage was das Böse ist
und da habe ich dagegen argumentiert
dass wir von dem Bösen sprechen sollen
wie so eine dunkle Macht der existiert
sind immer wenn wir sagen was ist böse
ganz konkret sein und auf Handlungen
Auto auf Strategien oder auch
meinetwegen auch auf Strukturen
hindeuten aber nicht so im nebulösen
bleiben weil sonst trifft die Kritik von
denen hier drei genannten Philosophen
auf jeden Fall zu es hängt also immer
damit zusammen wie wir den Begriff des
Bösen verwenden auf wen missbräuchlich
verwenden oder auf ihren philosophisch
sinnvoll kritisch gebrauchen und das ist
das Ziel dieser Vorlesung Grundbegriffe
der praktischen Philosophie alle
kritisch zu betrachten und zu
hinterfragen also ich glaube eben nicht
dass er sagt Franzi damit Recht hat ich
glaube wir können auf jeden Fall den
Begriff des Bösen als Begriff fassen und
ich glaube auch dass man mit einer
Problemlösung den Begriff des Bösen oder
dem Problem des Bösen auf die Spur
kommen kann natürlich ist immer die
Frage können wir das Böse wenn wir den
Begriff des Bösen verstanden haben
selbst lösen also wenn damit die
Erwartung verbunden wäre dass wenn wir
verstanden haben was das Böse ist wenn
wir den Begriff des Bösen eindeutig
definiert haben das dann vielleicht
sogar das Böse wenn es überhaupt gibt
aus der Welt verschwindet ich glaube da
würden wir uns als Philosophen und
Philosophen zu ernst nehmen wir können
Begriffe klären wir können Begriffe
kritisieren Begriffe in ihrer Verwendung
ja kritisch betrachten aber damit ist
natürlich dann noch nicht das Problem
des Bösen aus der Welt geschafft es sei
denn man es gelingt einem den Begriff
des Bösen so zu bestimmen dass wir damit
auch unsere Neigungen in letzter
Konsequenz mal so etwas wäre böse
Handlung zu kommen dadurch irgendwie
aufklären uns über unsere Motive klar
wird und das könnte dann in einem
vermittelten Schritt tatsächlich dazu
beitragen dass die Welt besser wird oder
weniger böse ist aber das sollten wir
uns als Philosophie und Philosophen
natürlich nicht überschätzen und auch
nicht überfordern und darüber
diskutieren immer jetzt gleich mal ein
bisschen also wir haben gesehen man kann
hier treffen drüber diskutieren
einerseits haben wir die Intuition zu
sagen wir können böse Handlungen wenn
sie wirklich böse grausam sind nicht
verstehen dafür können wir kein
Verständnis aufbringen weil Verständnis
aufzubringen bedeuten würde hinter der
Handlung gute grün zu sehen der
Grundbegriff ist natürlich vieldeutig
motivationale Gründe gute Gründe
zwingende Gründe rationale Gründe und
ein zwingender Grund war das sicherlich
nicht ein böses Verbrechen zu Beginn
aber wir haben auch eine andere
Bedeutung fünf Grund eben von
Nachvollziehbarkeit im Sinne Erklärung
wenn man schaut was für Motive haben
eine Rolle gespielt so dass man zwischen
Innensicht in den Perspektive und
objektive Außenperspektive unterscheidet
und so könnte man dieses Problem
auflösen jetzt
möchte ich eben das noch mal ein
bisschen fortsetzen also die Begriffe
des Guten Bösen sind vieldeutig und
problematisch hängt immer von den
jeweiligen Kontexten ab wie wir die
Begriffe verwenden
und wir müssen eben wenn wir den Begriff
des Bösen als philosophisch sinnvollen
Begriff verstehen wollen andere Begriffe
als ebenfalls sinnvoll voraussetzen das
heißt nicht dass es diese Realitäten
gibt dass diese Begriffe Geltung haben
sondern nur konzeptuell müssen wir davon
ausgehen dass diese Begriffe sinnvoll
sind wenn wir davon reden wollen dass
der Begriff des Bösen sinnvoll ist
nämlich sowas wie Normativität und zwar
auch möglichst objektive Normativität
objektiv feststellbare Normativität was
ist absolut objektiv gut und schlecht
das müssen wir voraussetzen dass es
sowas so ein Kriterium gibt um überhaupt
den Begriff des Bösen sind zu können
wenn wir keine Objektivität der Moral
haben können wir nicht objektiv von
etwas bösen sprechen den Willens Begriff
ne weil natürlich immer wir haben es
gesehen böse Handlungen durch Motive
motivationale Gründe auch bestimmt sind
innere Handlung
zum Beispiel Hass ist glaube ich nicht
nur eine Emotion sondern Hass kann als
etwas
volitionales willensmäßiges verstanden
werden Hass tritt ja nicht einfach so
von heute auf morgen auf so bleibt jetzt
wird der hass-schalter umgelegt erstmal
war ich freundlich positiv gestimmt und
jetzt bin ich plötzlich nicht nur
gehässig sondern Hass erfüllt dann noch
einen Unterschied ich glaube das hast
genauer beschrieben ist als eine innere
Handlung genauso wie Neid aber darüber
können wir auch noch mal diskutieren
Neid würde ich sagen haben ja diskutiert
in der Vorlesung im Kontext der
Gerechtigkeit mach auch oben rechts den
Link noch mal zu der Sitzung rein Neid
ist nicht nur eine unangenehme Erfindung
eine Emotion sondern eine Einstellung
gegenüber einer anderen Person und ich
glaube auch die Formierung des Neid ist
mit seiner Komplexität lässt sich als
eine innere Handlung verstehen genauso
auch scheint mir der hasst letztendlich
Strukturen eine inneren Hand Lösung zu
haben weil eben der Hass auch der
rechtfertigt sich der muss natürlich
auch mit Gründen operieren die Person
die Hass empfindet die richtet sich auf
ein Gegner die schießt sich
gewissermaßen ein auf ein Gegner und
hegt natürlich Fantasien den häufig
zerstörungsphantasien sind weil da da
geht einiges vor sich im Hass das ist
nicht einfach nur so eine Emotion die da
so explodiert sind da hat einiges davor
schon stattgefunden und das müssen wir
natürlich als Philosophie als
Philosophen im Kontext der
moralpsychologie sondern das ist nicht
mit der Psychologie zu verwechseln
sondern nur halb Psychologie müssen wir
das phänomenologisch und begrifflich
ergründe genauso praktische Vernunft
muss vorausgesetzt werden wenn wir vom
Bösen sprechen weil natürlich auch hier
Motive und Überlegung eine Rolle spielt
rationalen motivationale Gründe hatte
ich schon erwähnt Absichten Intentionen
Ziele auf etwas hinsetzen etwas zu
ziehen
meine Handlung die dann natürlich am
Ende böse ist aber wenn ich selbst eine
Handlung tue die am Ende böse ist
objektiv wir setzen ja wieder die
Objektivität der Moral voraus kann man
durch alles bestreiten aber wird jetzt
hier einfach mal vorausgesetzt dann
müssen wir wohl auch sowas wie
Selbsttäuschung annehmen den wer tut
schon willentlich das Böse im vollen
Bewusstsein des Bösen also wirklich
unter Berücksichtigung aller Umstände
sowohl des Leids was er oder sie an
einer anderen Person ausrichtet als auch
desjenigen was natürlich auf den oder
die zurückfällt der oder die böse
handelt da kann man natürlich häufig
sagen das ist Willensschwäche ja völlig
irrational ich glaube sie gesagt nicht
ich glaube wir brauchen hier einen
anspruchsvollen Begriff von
Selbsttäuschung und darüber werden in
der nächsten Vorlesung nächste Woche
ausführlich diskutieren kann ich glaube
sind Schlüsselbegriff der
Selbsttäuschung der muss aber natürlich
kritisch wie alle philosophischen
Begriffe analysiert und von anderen
Verwandten Begriffen abgegrenzt und
kontextualisiert werden damit er sich
dabei nicht nur um so eine Trivialität
handelt wie auch jetzt dachte ich ich
hätte ein Euro in meinem Geldbeutel aber
ich habe doch zwei Euro gehabt ist in
diesem Sinne reden wir hier nicht von
Selbsttäuschung sondern das sind wieder
Motive
Motivationen im Hintergrund Strategien
die wieder darauf hindeuten dass auch
Selbsttäuschung eine Form von innerer
Handlung ist das ist so jedenfalls meine
These und ich glaube über den Begriff
der Selbsttäuschung sind eines
anspruchsvollen Begriffs können wir
das Problem ist bösen besser in den
Griff bekommen auch viele anderen
Phänomen dann haben sie eine Abstimmung
gemacht und zwar erfreuliche Weise
wieder 22 wir sind jetzt ziemlich
Konstanz in der Partizipation
durch sie ich glaube das letzte Mal
waren es auch 22 also ist das Böse
rational natürlich ist das wieder eine
Frage die so eigentlich gar nicht
gestellt werden kann die Frage ist viel
zu mehrdeutig viel zu viel deutlich aber
darum geht es ja auch gar nicht es geht
hier darum Intuitionen rückgemeldet zu
bekommen und dann darüber zu diskutieren
gewissermaßen im Sinne einer
experimentellen Philosophie sie sehen
die Fragen sind auch nicht genau
identisch also die Mehrheit von ihm sagt
ja 55% 45 nein und diese relativ
Ausgeglichenheit spricht dafür dass es
Gründe dafür und dagegen gibt natürlich
hängt das vielleicht wieder damit
zusammen dass der Begriff des rationalen
fehlt deutlich ist ne daran kann das
häufig auch so eine ein Umfrageergebnis
liegen und dann sind wir gefordert
diesen Begriff des rationalen mit Blick
auf die Fragestellung auf das Böse den
Begriff ist natürlich auch klären weiter
zu analysieren das sind wir als
Philosophie und Philosophen gefordert
wenn es um Grundbegriffe der praktischen
Philosophie geht jetzt
sind noch fragen da zu diesem Komplex
ich glaube wir haben darüber ausführlich
diskutiert die jetzt können wir
weitermachen und uns mit dem
eigentlichen Thema der heutigen
Vorlesung befassen nämlich mit dem Thema
moralisch Zurechenbarkeit und
Verantwortung das ist natürlich auch ein
ganz wichtiger Grundbegriff der
praktischen Philosophie warum weil er
letztendlich uns Handlungen zu schreiben
lässt ja also es geht um Zuordnungen und
es geht natürlich auch immer so ein
bisschen wenn man von Verantwortung
spricht um was normatives in der Regel
also man kann natürlich auch davon
sprechen ich rechne dir diese Handlung
zu ich führe diese Handlung auf dich
zurück auf deinen Schluss und damit ist
überhaupt nichts normatives angesprochen
es geht einfach nur darum zu fragen wer
hat das getan
ich habe irgendjemand was getan völlig
neutral weder gut noch böse wir wollen
einfach wissen wer was getan hat es geht
natürlich auch aber in der Regel rechnen
wir etwas dann zu oder sind wir dann
interessiert eine Handlung zuzurechnen
wenn die Handlung schlecht war weil mir
scheint es sozusagen das gute Handlung
in der Regel gar nicht so zugerechnet
werden das ist auch ein Problem dass wir
vielleicht auch viel zu selten gute
Handlungen zu rechnen und eben
dementsprechend auch belohnen und
würdigen wir sind das ein bisschen immer
nur auf schlechte ausgerichtet ist
vielleicht auch ein Problem der Welt
sich die wir haben was muss
vorausgesetzt werden damit uns eine
Handlung zugerechnet werden kann das ist
ganz ähnliche Frage wie welche Begriffe
müssen vorausgesetzt werden als sinnvoll
als gültig damit wir den Begriff des
Bösen verstehen können natürlich immer
hypothetisch man kann natürlich immer
sagen der Begriff der zurechtbarkeit der
Verantwortung ist sinnvoll es gibt nicht
in der Welt Verantwort und
Zurechenbarkeit kann man mit gewissen
Argumenten sagen dann muss man aber
immer auch noch sagen welche anderen
Probleme man sich damit dann einkauft
also immer alles explizieren und immer
im Kontext schauen wir gehen jetzt mal
davon aus dass der Begriff der
Verantwortung sinnvoll ist dass der
berechtigt ist dass wir davon ausgehen
weiter kann man sich fragen wer kann
alles für Handlungen moralisch zum
Beispiel verantwortlich sein
individuelle oder auch kollektive Person
vielleicht auch nicht menschliche Tiere
spannend auch hier stellt sich die Frage
was müssen wir voraussetzen damit eine
eine Person ein Wesen ein Subjekt für
etwas moralisch verantwortlich sein kann
sie sehen darum geht es immer in diesem
dieser Vorlesung was muss vorausgesetzt
werden als sinnvoll damit wir sinnvoll
von einem Begriff sprechen können
jetzt möchte ich sie noch auch eine ganz
ganz
wichtige Internetseite hinweisen nämlich
die Stanford and cyclerpedia aufgelassen
wer von ihnen hat die schon mal
aufgesucht
also einige das ist jetzt von mir ein
Werbung aber keine Sorge gar nicht
finanziell interessiert die Seite ist ja
vollständig kostenlos und es handelt
sich dabei wohl um eine der besten
internet-entzyklopädien weltweit an der
besten freien kostenlosen und immer
aktuell gehaltenen Internet Enzyklopädie
und den Link finden Sie hier kann ich
aller wärmstens empfehlen gehen sie
drauf Artikel sind zu allen möglichen
philosophischen Begriffen oder Problemen
von Expertinnen und Experten verfasst
ist alles angelsächsisch formuliert muss
man eben die Hürde gehen aber es lohnt
sich hier mal nachzulesen bei allen
möglichen Themen wie zum Beispiel auch
bei diesem Thema moralische
Verantwortung und Zurechenbarkeit auch
hier lohnt sich überhaupt bei allen
möglichen Grundbegriffen auch der
praktischen Philosophie Einblick in
diese Enzyklopädie
ja
wir können jetzt sagen das ist Problem
moralische zurechtbarkeit und
Verantwortung sich vor allem im Falle
von moralisch bösen oder wenn wir es
anders wollen unmoralischen Handlungen
stellt ich hatte schon gesagt selten und
zwar leider wie mir scheint wird gefragt
wer war verantwortlich für diese gute
Handlung das ist schon fast ein
Widerspruch wenn man so eine Frage
stellt dann wird man sich wundern wer
hat das getan das war gut so eine sehr
gute Handlung ein sehr gutes Ergebnis
wer hat das getan bitte mehr wir wollen
jemanden verantwortlich dafür machen für
das Gute das ist das klingt seltsam und
also verantwortlich machen klingt schon
so wie beschuldigen aber wir wollen wir
wollen wissen wem diese Handlung
zurechtbar ist ja man könnte so reden
ist okay ja irgendwie ein es wurde eine
ein Beispiel ist es wurde eine Person
gerettet aus dem Bodensee und die
Retterin der Retter ist verschwunden und
dann will die gerettete Person wissen
wer mir da geholfen gibt es ab und zu
liest man ab und zu
und klar weil der gute rette die gute
Retterin einfach so bescheiden war die
Person geredet hat und dann verschwunden
ist ja wollte kein Held sein kann
in solchen Fällen fragt man das häufig
aber in der Regel fragt man wer hat
schon wieder seinen willenbodensee
abgelassen wer hat den Bodensee schon
wieder verschmutzt wer hat die oder
verschmutzt ja gab es doch vor einiger
Zeit diese Verschmutzung dieses Flusses
wo man immer fragt wer hat jetzt wieder
getan also in der Regel geht es um Dinge
die ja nicht so nicht so toll sind wenn
man nach Zürich einbarkeit fragt
wir werden für moralisch böse bzw
unmoralische Handlungen nicht aber in
der Regel für unsere Maximum für unseren
Willen verurteilt und ziehen Vorwürfe
auf uns mit verurteilt meine ich jetzt
nicht vor Gericht verurteilt sondern wir
bekommen Tadel also man ist billigt
unsere Handlung
missbilligt man unsere maximum na ja das
würde ja voraussetzen dass man diese
Maxim irgendwie nach außen kommuniziert
also ich könnte natürlich
jeden Tag meine Maxime obwohl maximal
nicht immer recht konstant sind meine
Maxim ändern sie nicht Vertrag zu Tag so
definiert jedenfalls kann die Maxim ich
könnte alle meine willensgrundsätze oder
meine Intentionen könnte ich Ihnen jeden
Tag hier an die Tafel schreiben
die müssen natürlich auch wahr sein und
dann könnten sie mich dafür kritisieren
ja aber das Wesen der Maxime und unsere
Intention ist eben das dass die nicht
klar zu Tage treten man kann von den
Handlungen auf Intentionen rückschließen
aber dieser Schluss ist immer
problematisch wir können einfach nicht
in die Köpfe andere Menschen
hineinblicken ja das ist immer das
Problem auch wenn man dann irgendwelche
niederen Beweggründe oder so vor Gericht
geltend machen möchte oder Heimtücke ich
glaube aber auch selbst dass das in
juristischen Kontexten problematisch ist
so ein Psychologie selbst dann müssen
wir nämlich hier Hilfsmittel verwenden
ja also um plausibel zu machen dass das
die Motive gewesen sind die Motive
treten nicht zu Tage und die Motive
werden häufig verschleiert das ist auch
noch das Problem ich bin mir manchmal
gar nicht direkt über meine Motivlage
bewusst warum Stichwort Selbsttäuschung
das trägt auch dazu bei dass ich mir
selbst meine eigenen motivationsbasis
nicht bewusst bin das macht die Sache
total kompliziert deswegen ist in der
Regel so dass wir uns an den Handlung
orientieren und die entsprechend
kritisieren und einer Person zu
schreiben aber auch
gegebenenfalls vorwerfen
damit wir für unsere Handlung zur
moralischen Verantwortung bezogen werden
können müssen wir das ist jetzt einer
dieser Begriffe der wichtig ist
Willensfreiheit besitzen
anders gesagt es wird uns vorgeworfen
jetzt im
bösen oder unmoralischen dass wir auch
anders hätten handeln können dass wir
also alternative Möglichkeiten der Wahl
hatten dies jedoch bewusst nicht taten
also wir sind nicht irgendeiner
willenschwäche unterlegen oder irgendwie
einem Irrtum ich dachte das wäre aber
gut gewesen aber es war dann falsch oder
habe ich mich wirklich das tut mir total
leid aber es war wirklich eine Absichten
man wird das nicht gelten lassen wenn
man einem wirklich
berechtigterweise das wird immer
vorausgesetzt also es geht ja wirklich
objektiv gerechtfertigte zu schreiben
oder Vorwürfe kann man natürlich immer
darüber diskutieren ob die Vorwürfe
wirklich berechtigt sind oder überhaupt
Sinn macht jemanden was vorzuziehen aber
gehen wir mal davon aus der Begriff der
Verantwortung und der Zürich einbarkeit
ist sinnvoll und ist berechtigten vor
dieser Vorwurf dann müssen wir
konzentrieren
voraussetzen dass diese Person der etwas
deswegen unmoralisches vorgeworfen wird
dass die auch anders hätte handeln
können sie musste nicht zu handeln und
das ist aber trotzdem tat obwohl sie
vielleicht hätte wissen können oder ein
bisschen können müssen dass das nicht
okay ist sie hat also das irgendwie auch
bewusst getan ob sie jetzt bewusst
direkt zum Beispiel wenn es im
schlimmsten Fall um das Böse geht das
Böse getan hat ist noch mal eine andere
Frage da gibt es eine große Debatte ob
man überhaupt bewusst das Böse wenn man
sich so wirklich ganz schlimm vorstellt
tun kann als sicherlich wird das Böse
ein seltensten Fällen von Menschen die
böse handeln als solches als böses
angestrebt sondern es erscheint immer
als etwas Gutes oder als etwas
gerechtfertigt ist
und darüber wollen wir jetzt mal so ein
bisschen
diskutieren ich will aber noch ein
bisschen was hinzufügen das Problem
moralische Zurechenbarkeit betrifft also
auch die Frage nach Willensfreiheit und
jetzt kommt natürlich wieder das
begriffsnetz vor ihrer geistigen
Anschauung entsteht das unten links die
ganzen Verästelungen es geht um das
Problem von kompatibilismus
liebertarianismus und der terminismus
alles geht letztendlich wenn wir
jemanden etwas vorwerfen darum ob er
hart oder determiniert war spricht keine
alternativen Möglichkeiten der Wahl
hatte oder ob er oder sie sie hatte
warum geht es jetzt endlich
und jetzt möchte ich Ihnen noch mal
dieses Problem des Konsequenz arguments
vor Augen führen das haben Sie
sicherlich schon mal hier kennengelernt
von einem gewissen Peter Van inwagon und
weil es so schönes möchte ich es ihnen
noch mal vorstellen was sagt nämlich
jetzt
angesichts des Problems ob uns wirklich
etwas zugerechnet werden kann zum
Beispiel etwas böse ist sagte if die
Germanys true then our acts are the
consequences of the Lord nature and
events in the remote hast but it is not
up to us what we went on before we will
is
it up to us what the Lords of nature are
der for the consequentes auf dies things
inclubing our present Ex or not up to
use darüber müssen wir jetzt mal ein
bisschen diskutieren also ist das
wirklich wahr dass
erstens der Determinismus so gilt und
das zweitens wenn er gilt dass dann
dieses Konsequenz Argument richtig ist
und uns unsere Handlungen gar nicht
zugerechnet werden können weil diese
Handlung ja Faktoren unterliegen die vor
unserer Geburt liegen ja bevor wir
geboren wurden darüber wollen wir jetzt
mal ein bisschen diskutieren
ja wir haben gesehen diese Frage ist
sehr zentral gilt das Konsequenz
Argument oder gilt nicht wo können wir
ansetzen wir müssen unterscheiden
zwischen zwei Formen von zürichbarkeit
von bloß kausaler zu riechenbarkeit und
von stärker verstandener moralisch zu
solchen Krankheit
man könnte die These vertreten das
kausale zu rechnenbarkeit mit dem
Konsequenz Argument kompatibel ist weil
dabei nicht Freiheit und alternative
Möglichkeiten vorausgesetzt werden
können die Frage ist natürlich die ob
wenn wir nur von kausaler zu euch halt
sprechen wir die Kausalkette dann nicht
noch viel weiter zurückverfolgen müssen
als bis zu uns als ursächlichen Faktoren
das möchte ich nur zu Diskussion still
jetzt kann man sich noch weiter fragen
diese Frage wurde noch mehr
radikalisiert ist moralische
Verantwortung überhaupt möglich das
Konsequenz Argument sagt es gibt ein
Problem und es gibt von einem
gegenwärtigen Philosophen mit dem Titel
den Namen geilen storeson der ein
Aufsatz geschrieben hat die
impossibility of more responsibility
1994 der hat ausdrücklich dagegen
argumentiert der hat gesagt moralische
Verantwortung gibt es nicht sie sehen
das ja schon am Titel er spricht wie
gesagt von moralischer Verantwortung
nicht von kausaler verantwortlich das
ist schon mal ganz wichtig jetzt gehen
wir mal dieses Argument gemeinsam durch
das sind jetzt acht Schritte dieses
Arguments mit denen er versuchen möchte
objektiv zu begründen warum wir nicht
moralisch verantwortlich für unsere
Handlung sein können erstens interested
in free action wie ein particulilly
interested in actions it up performance
to reflexions
also das führt wieder zum Begriff des
Grundes eine freie Handlung braucht
Gründe Interesse
function of how one is mentaly speaking
it is also function of once hate wants
stranks plays in time and soon but the
mental factors a crucial when
morrisibility is in question also
das was wir tun
entsteht aus einer Verfasstheit die uns
beschreibt wir handeln nur so wie wir
sind klar sonst können uns ja nicht
zugerechnet werden wir handeln so wie
wir sind aber wir können verschiedene
Weisen dessen unterscheiden wie wir oder
was wir sind wir können von uns als
mentale Wesen sprechen oder als
natürliche Wesen wir haben eine Höhe ein
Stärke ein Ort in Raum und Zeit dann
werden wir nur als physikalische
Gegenstände angesehen aber wenn es um
moralische Verantwortung geht dann
spielt natürlich die mentale
Verfasstheit die Haup unsere Handlung
sind Folgen unserer mentalen Vorgänge
wenn wir sie verstehen wollen so Yvonne
is to be true of responsable for how one
Acts Beach responsable for how one is
Mentalist speaking at least insurgen
respect also wenn es jetzt darum geht
was wir mental sind weil nur so unsere
Handlung verständlich werden und nicht
durch unsere Größe unsere physikalischen
Eigenschaften dann müssen wir natürlich
verantwortlich dafür sein was wir sind
also was wir mental sind nicht was wir
körperlich sind das haben wir nicht in
der Hand wie groß wir sind man kann ein
bisschen was tun aber in der Regel ist
es festgelegt
weiter geht's but to be Trude response
before one is Mentalist speaking is the
Respekts have Brot it up out that one is
the way one is Mentalist speaking insert
hätte das
have to be the way one ist menschliches
speaking
die Chancen to be the way one is
mentalistik in surten respects and one
must have sexseen in bringing it about
that one is that way gut also man muss
also verantwortlich sein wie man ist in
mentaler Hinsicht und man muss sich
sogar dafür entschieden haben also muss
die alternativen Möglichkeiten eventuell
sogar auch gehabt haben sich dafür
entschieden zu haben weiter geht's wir
haben noch drei weitere Schritte
fünftens but one Kenneth really be set
to choose in der conscious reason
fashion to be the way what is
menschliche speaking in any respektive
already equipt bis with some principles
of Joyce preferences pro editudeals in
the light of which und juices
also um überhaupt
uns zu wählen uns mental wählen zu
können das ist die Voraussetzung von
moralisch Verantwortung müssen wir doch
schon existieren wir können uns doch nur
wählen wenn wir schon existieren
sie sehen das Problem also wie können
wir uns selbst wählen wenn wir noch gar
nicht existieren
geht noch weiter noch weitere Schritte
sechstens Baden to be true die
responsible on account of having chosen
to be the way one is mental speaking in
certain Respekt von
once having principles of choice in the
light of witch one
muss man auch noch für die Prinzipien
der Wahl verantwortlich sein bad for
this to be so one must have Josy PI in
the reasons Intension
hat Ford this is seven to be one must or
ready have some principles in the light
of Switch und
Schauspielers
also das Argument läuft einfach so ab
wir müssen Ursache unserer selbst sein
aber um Ursachen unsere selbst zu sein
müssen wir schon existieren und die
Gründe für unsere Entscheidung die
müssen immer schon in vorhanden sein die
können wir natürlich nicht selbst
bestimmen ohne das schon Gründe für
unsere Handlungen vorausgesetzt wurden
sonst könnten wir gar nicht uns
entscheiden also letztendlich ist das
ein Vorwurf der Zirkularität könnte man
sagen man setzt immer schon das voraus
was man eigentlich zeigen möchte dass
wir nämlich frei entscheiden können das
ist das Argument gegen moralische
Verantwortung natürlich für das zu einer
Art von Skeptizismus und darüber wollen
wir jetzt auch noch weiter diskutieren
bevor wir auf dem begrifflichen Kontext
von moralische zuwendbarkeit noch mein
Detail zu sprechen kommen ja wir haben
gesehen man kann dieses Argument an
verschiedenen Punkten kritisieren man
kann natürlich auch hier wiederum ein
Vergleich zu Harry Frank wird hinstellen
mit diesem nicht zirkulären Argument zu
dem Regress Argument immer höher Stufe
die vol schon in der nächsten Vorlesung
ist mich nur noch als Ausblick geben
werden wir auf die Begriffe eingehen die
wir als sinnvoll voraussetzen müssen
wenn wir moralische Verantwortung
versuchen wollen zu bestimmen ich glaube
der Begriff der Person ist wichtig der
Begriff der Individualität man kann
darüber diskutieren ob auch kollektive
Personen wenn es sie gibt moralisch
verantwortlich sein können ganz
schwierig darüber diskutieren der
willensbegriff ist wichtig
Willensfreiheit ist wichtig Autonomie
Selbstbestimmung der Grund es muss
Gründe geben Normativität wenn du
moralische Verantwortung geht müssen wir
Objektivität der Moral annehmen
die Moralität die Normativität muss
moralisch entstanden werden es muss eine
Handlung geben die man zu rechnen kann
und die Hand muss eben gut oder böse
oder moralisch und moralisch
qualifiziert werden können und das hängt
natürlich dann mit der Zurechenbarkeit
das haben sie sehen die zurigenbarkeit
setzt diese ganzen Begriffe und noch
viele mehr voraus ist sicherlich noch
nicht alle die ein sinnvoller Begriff
von zürichbarkeit als sinnvoll
voraussetzt dann bedanke mich für die
Aufmerksamkeit und die Diskussion bis
zur nächsten Vorlesung